[拍手]
自分にわー
何もねぇこれじゃんですそれでこのはずなミューズメットパーク8分後かなんですけど
もご覧の通り
何もないんですよ矢先想像したんですけど
女今こういう自粛期間でみんな家にいなきゃいけないんで私もずっと家にいるわけなん
ですけども僕が最近ハマってることを2つありますひとつ目敦盛2つへ
ぶっきんですまあスッキリでが筋トレ前半ですね腹筋だけやっててもちょっとダメだな
と思った最近標品がを鍛えてるんですけども
筋トレなんですよ時代運はもう砂利の時代は終わってこれからの音が間違いなくも
ムキムキでも増勢を守るようない楽しい体で来ないとプールをある日
ナンバーであの僕が筋トレしてる道具が意外とシンプルなんだけどもこちら
これだけですおこしょう炒めないためにマット引いてまた真面目でこのアブローラーで
復帰したり頭だってこうやってするぐらいしかもないですよ
せっかく家にいる時間が長いんだったらもっと派手に行きたいだろう
はい
全部金鳥グッズべきで私弾みシャツは筋トレずっといいねやってるんですけども反対か
ジム行ったんですよ
着たい方わからないんで自分の構築とかでもこうやってみたんですけどそれ
家でやればいいんじゃないかというわけでせっかく家に大きなスペースがある理由に
いる時間が長い特に欲しいものもねー
[音楽]
鬼女いくつ買おうかということで結構色々貼ってみたんで今日この使おう
筋肉トレーニングズームに改造していきたいとおもいますライガー組
まずは僕の勝手な妄想なんですけども筋トレする上で大事なんだか言うかだと思うん
ですよいかに安全に地面でも筋トレできる空間ができるかということでまずは安全に
マットをひいて行きたいと思いますちょっで
カップの熱を上げていきましょうもうこれで敷き詰めていくのが一番良いと思います
イケてるんですね
ああああああ
ではないでしょうか弥栄敷き詰めてゆく
ん
それでは今だけ他人でだいぶ拾いがこれ実は候補南部ちょっと後になんとかします次よ
がんばっていきましょう
またさ知ってるんですよこういうマットでやるのもいいんですけどやっぱちゃんとよ
がんばったみたいなカラダに良いマットを使うトレーニングがベストっていう意味で
これとは別にちゃんとした何かありました
うわぁいいですねーこういうその辺でめっちゃ体に優しい
大
そして俺がマイクラつか受けた納豆
エアー女性は次行きましょうインターダイバーコイン種ですラブリーデイ
より3つの買ったっけなぁあります
もう去ったぺるんっすすごいーっ
ブーバーコースねバーイロス
すっああ
こりゃいいわ
voodoo
これどんなこと言いますと思ってるだけでトレーニングできるらしいです
ブーバーし
ああああああああ
じゃあねもうちょっと一人だと分野でちょっと協力しながら作っていきます
トレーニング器具
はぁ
あああああ終わった
はっはいすぎでこれなんですけどもうねがいろんなトレーニングできるんですけど多分
僕が打ってきたんだいらっしゃるですねこうやって好捕
これは出た不均衡も期待できと思います
4日付の
野営奴は次行きましょう入った上でかなり検討中こうなってきましたが一番大事なもの
鏡何が一番とりあえず気がします筋トレでき自分持ち霊との戦いなんでその
筋トレして働くかっこよくなっていく自分を見てもちろんにつながるんだよなんなら
そのに一番大事だと思っを超えていますそれだけで現れ
で木の板に大変の相模をつきました
[音楽]
ブーブーようじゃ
ん
で僕などで関西の酒幹線ぽよこれ
[音楽]
おおーーフェラバイブできました
まずはなりますどんどん作っていきましょうはいで結婚できてきたんですけどまだ
ちょっとたくさんね左右に分かれて作っていきましょう
こっちがこれ誰かの方区切ってあるやつ
エコ違う勤務 ok ですってみましょう
[音楽]
ベンチプレス起きません完成しますシュー
ってこれ
大三川貼るぜ
はいというわけでファーブの器具になりました
[音楽]
いやー
やまなか家いない ok だよ
ん
いい
はいえー
goo
ええええええ
キター
ok おおお
ホレたぜしましたーー
me
レギュラーの本大会近所いていく作るとなると約10時間使うことが分かりました
はっはっは
というわけでねぇあってトレーリング10
たーーー
ガーン
ご紹介してみましょう
っていう方こちらだって来ませんですそれを大きめ平らなやつですよく見え友達いると
かで
以上3しこれがの下だけなるが欲しいっと花と回しグラップ痩せそうなよねー
パーンそしてこれでこれはもうねえっまだちょっと前ですけどもっとブーブーらこう
いう do s 市阿古でぱどですねこれじゃあ4パデッリいろいろできます相撲はた
そりゃあし
いいんでございますこれで子吹き空気が澄んだよねこれをの足は下落したバブします
さあそしてこれでこれも無いと言わ
これあー足を鍛えられてきます
応募してこれでも大きな競技を決めることもできます
ふぅ
ただあ例えばわけですねこういうでなら後年っとリスト化したりなんか自分でちょっと
を去ったくらいなんですけどいろんなプレイに方法ができるわけですか
そして最後松井やろバイクですちょっとは草原になるんですけれどもこうやって国や
つめ
はい
こういうことができますよとそして挙句の果てには音楽です花王引きながら鶏肉すると
大事だと思ってその日9やりすぎました
はい定款でなんですけどいかがでしょうかたぶん2 na だとこんなふうヤバいと
思ってほんと最近舟足見ていったら筋トレって言っても過言ではないけれどでこの場所
でそれ
大できればいいなと思いますし空中に先の人とだけを見てつかんでいきたいと思うんで
この子わー
[音楽]
voodoo
あっちょ